- Hi, I'm Ocha.
It's amazing to be here at re:Invent.
In the past three days,
I've learned a lot from
the sessions, mixers,
and fellow startups on
how they're developing AI.
So in this session, it's
time for me to contribute
on our learnings in scaling Gen AI
in the real-world healthcare.
So this is the agenda for today.
First of all, I would like
to introduce you to Heidi,
our journey on becoming one
of the biggest AI scribe
in the world and how we
are navigating through
the healthcare system with AI.
And at the end of this lightning talk,
I hope you can get some valuable takeaways
to contribute back to the
product you're building.
So before we start, hands up
who has been to the doctor
and then felt like you felt rushed
or like you couldn't get
your doctor's attention
because staring at the computer.
Yeah, looks like everyone. (laughs)
It's unfortunate because
oftentimes it's at this moment
we felt frustrated,
but it's actually not
the doctor's intention
because they had to deal
with administrative tasks
of writing notes.
So Heidi is here to solve that problem.
At Heidi, we want clinicians
to enjoy what they do
without the hassle of the admin,
giving time back to the doctors,
and provide better patient experience.
And that is just one of our
initiatives on our mission
to double the world's healthcare capacity
by providing an AI care partner.
So here's Heidi in action.
So imagine you're a doctor
and you're currently
having consultation session
with a patient.
Once you start transcribing,
Heidi will generate clinical
notes without any modification
or further action needed,
and that's not the only
thing Heidi can do.
Based on the templates that they created.
doctors can now use the
notes as their reference
to create patient explain a little.
Doctors can then ask AI after this,
ask AI to do clinical research.
And even Heidi after this can
give suggestions to doctors
on the task that they need to do
as a follow up of the consultation.
This is exciting because
doctors can now focus on patient
and get Heidi to do
all of the admin stuff.
So a little about our journey.
Our founder, Tom Kelly,
who was practicing doctor,
started build chatbot tool named Oscer
to help medical students
in mastering their clinical examination
using early transformers model.
Seeing some success, we
jumped to full healthcare
where we created like a care
platform to support doctors
and enhance patient care.
This works for a while until Gen AI emerge
where we can leverage the capability
of non-deterministic outputs
with focus on one workflow,
clinical note generation,
and landed on Heidi, an ambient AI scribe
that eases documentation burden.
We've grown out of a small
company in Australia,
now we're recognized as global player.
Looking at the numbers,
Heidi is the most used AI scribe globally.
370,000 plus clinicians on Heidi,
10 million consults per month,
number one AI scribe by adoption in Canada
and backed by well-known investors.
And this is just a start.
And that's me.
So been with Heidi with
about four years now.
One of the founding engineers of Heidi,
used to solo developing like software,
infra observability, security compliance
and all that fun stuff.
And now that we're growing
at lightning speed,
I'm focusing on platform engineering,
giving engineers the tools
and experience they need
to develop securely and efficiently.
So, and let's get to the first lesson,
which is a challenge of AI in healthcare,
which is building confidence in AI.
So when we start developing Heidi,
we immediately think of
how we can personalize
and customize notes
so that it can write
the same as clinicians.
Our custom template
has been a huge success
and doctors loved it,
but as an engineer we keep thinking on
how we can make it more
efficient, thinking about latency,
thinking about contact windows of LLM.
But as more clinicians use Heidi,
we encounter more unique cases
related to their specialty.
For example, how do we get the tone,
the specific of our note
summary, correct for each doctor
so they feel confident
and they can rely on him?
This is where we realize that
truth is where that matter.
Healthcare requires clinical accuracy
and we were trying to
validate non-deterministic
outputs at scale.
You can't just write unit
tests for clinical empathy
or diagnostic nuance, we needed doctors.
So what this meant at the start,
so back then we only like
have a couple of doctors.
This meant we start giving like
doctors a Jupyter Notebook.
Each Jupyter Notebook is a
tool used by data scientists
to write code and experiment
and doctors can start
experiments connecting with LLM,
answer their prompts, the transcription,
change of temperature, and so on.
But the problem is that doctors
in the end have to aggregate
the results to summarize
all of the testing.
So to address that problem,
we started to provide
JupyterHub hosted on EC2
as collaboration tool so that
the doctors doesn't have to
consolidate everything in the end.
Clearly this is not going
to work for at scale.
So not every clinicians
or doctors is going
to be a coder, work okay
for like scrappy testing
with a small numbers of doctors.
So how do we scale it then?
So picture this.
How does a typical clinician
workflow look like in Heidi
for transcription and note generation?
So at first we needed
data points we can base
like when doing evaluation,
but how we're going to do
that in testing environment
because we can't use any user's data.
So one of the ways that the doctors do
is we can do some mock consultation
and have case studies with Heidi users.
But most importantly, the
most recent techniques
that we use is using LLM to
try to create synthetic data
to generate consultation both
in audio form and text form.
With enough data, clinicians
can start to do more evaluation
on word error rate,
template adherence check,
basically making sure that the templates
that clinicians made is
safe, medically safe,
hallucination rate check, and
this process is what we call
like clinicians in the loop.
As Heidi started to hire
and hire more clinicians,
the evaluation process
needs to be scalable.
At this stage, engineers started
to introduce more tooling
that can help clinicians
such as internal tooling
for evaluating flag sessions
to be reviewed than in
testing environment,
building connections between the sessions
and the LLM context to
gain better understanding
and also LLM as a judge
tool to do it at scale.
All of these processes can
be used as a feedback loop
to improve the model,
prompts, and medical safety.
It shape our product and
engineering decision hiring
and go to market.
So speaking about scaling,
scaling clinical experts,
it's one challenge.
The next is how we scale
Heidi outside of Australia.
When we set to expand Heidi
globally, we quickly realized
that healthcare isn't a single standard.
Like we encountered like
four distinct layers
that I can think of, of
complexity that we have
to solve simultaneously.
So first it's data sovereignty.
Wait, okay, first it's data sovereignty.
This isn't just about
storage or like about strict,
it's about strict data locality
and network architecture.
For example, in Australia,
we must strictly use ap-southeast-2
or ap-southeast-4, the
newest region in Melbourne,
whereas in the US, we
might utilize us-east-1
or us-west-2.
It's not just where the data is stored,
but it's also how it moves.
We need to ensure that data,
that workloads, stay private
using a well-architectured PPC network
to control exactly how system communicates
with each other within
those specific borders.
And the second is model availability.
If you're building solely
for US, it's lot of easy
because models are available everywhere.
Here in the US you can
pick almost every provider,
but the moment you try
to expand to new regions,
that luxury disappears.
We suddenly had to think
about other options
because the models we wanted
simply just not available
or not compliant in those local zones.
And third is medical reality itself.
A GP appointment in
Australia look very different
from primary care visit in New York.
It's not just about the
accent, it's training,
consultation flow, and
the medical terminology.
Heidi has to adapt to these nuances
to capture the consultation accurately.
And finally, we are
building on a shifting sand.
Gen AI is a new frontier
that is actively influencing
the regulatory space.
Navigating different regions
means managing different
compliance requirements simultaneously.
This isn't just a legal headache,
it directly affect our product roadmap,
our engineering decisions,
every single day.
So facing these four massive hurdles,
we had to architect a solution
that could handle them all.
So how did we actually
meet these challenges
from a technical perspective?
The answer lies in standardization.
So we need to make sure all
of our infrastructure in AWS
is standardized across
every single region.
We utilize infrastructure
as a code to ensure
that our deployment is consistent.
This gives us a flexible
architecture that allows us
to easily deploy into new region
without reinventing the wheel.
Essentially, we treat new regions
as plug-and-play templates.
You'll notice that there
is a EKS classic diagram.
It's a bit small, so I'm gonna
make it quite big over there.
This is central to our strategy
for model availability.
When when we're talking
about immediate availability,
we're entering new regions.
We use LM providers that
are already available
and compliant in that designated
region like Amazon Bedrock.
This solves immediate coldstar problem.
However, in the long term,
it is imperative for us
to have infrastructure that
can support self-hosted models.
This is where EKS shines since AWS EKS
supports most of the global regions,
once we have our
infrastructure template ready,
we can serve our own
inference models everywhere.
This hybrid approach, Bedrock
for speed and EKS for control,
solved the model availability globally.
But as I mentioned earlier,
healthcare isn't just
code, right, it's people.
Once the technical pipes has been laid,
we still face the massive
non-technical hurdle,
which is building trust.
Trust starts with speaking the language.
And I don't just mean French,
Spanish, I mean medicine.
We hire clinician ambassadors
in every region we operate in.
These are doctors who
believe in Heidi Mission
and provide specific
on the ground support.
These aren't just consultants.
They provide specific support
to ensure Heidi can speak
local medical dialect.
They validate that Heidi
doesn't just translate words,
but also understand
local practice patterns
ensuring the output feels
natural to GP in New York
or a specialist in Sydney.
Finally, we tackle the complex
regulatory requirements
through a rigorous compliance network.
All of these compliance
network like we establish
a dedicated internal
legal and compliance team
that manage the shifting
landscape to international laws.
We also work with external partners,
especially focusing on medical safety.
This ensures that we move
fast on infrastructure,
but we never compromise on safety.
By combining this plug-and-play,
technical architecture
with human in the loop trust strategy
we're able to scale globally
while staying local.
So if there is one thing
that I want you to walk away
with today is that technology
alone isn't the product.
What made Heidi successful was the release
of foundational model,
but what made us successful was the pivot.
We moved from the broad
care platform that tried
to do everything to focusing
on a single workflow
that brings immediate,
tangible value to doctors.
Don't try to boil the ocean,
just solve one painful problem perfectly.
And second, in a world of generative AI,
the human is more important than ever.
Doctors and clinicians are
the core part of the product.
We learn to treat our
subject matter experts,
not just as testers, but
also as our biggest asset.
They're the guardian of the quality.
And finally, for the builders in the room,
build a flexible
architecture from day one.
This isn't just about code quality,
it's about business survival.
It is this flexibility
that allows us to respond
to changing regulatory environments
and expand into new regions
with completely different requirements.
Your architecture should
be an enabler of expansion,
not a bottleneck.
And that's about it.
I hope you learn one or two
things from our journey.
And if you're interested
in building the future
of healthcare or have any
questions about Heidi,
I'd love to chat.
You can find more and
more on the left QR link.
You can find more about
Heidi on the left QR link
and you can find me on the
link on the right QR link,
and thank you.
(audience clapping)